my sims are going through a transition
the father just wants to make music but
the demands of his job as a stand-up
comedian are taking their toll mother
enjoys gardening and flirting with her
husband in equal measure but there are
so many plants to water that her social
life is suffering how appropriate then
that the sim series itself is undergoing
a transition the sims 4 is another
elegance and absorbing simulation of
daily life but it's clear even after a
few hours of playing it that something's
missing in advance of the review let's
take a look at the four biggest ways the
sims 4 drops the ball number one a
diminished sense of community the Sims
has always been about telling stories of
your own making but in The Sims 4 the
continuous world has been
compartmentalized once again and loading
screens separate you from the rest of
your neighborhood which is in and of
itself made up of small lots separated
by loading screens as a result of this
and other changes the stories I love
telling in previous games are now out of
reach I can no longer hop on a bike and
pedal across town to the gym if I get
hungry at the library I can't just walk
to the restaurant next door and grab a
bite it's no longer a neighborhood it's
a bunch of rooms with houses with the
rooms of their own number two it's just
generally stripped down getting back to
that storytelling it isn't just bike
rides that have been removed from my
personal stories there are no poles or
toddlers and babies are just static
things I like having a child and I'm
glad that you can still use genetics to
create a child that looks like her
parents but I will miss bonding with the
baby burping her and feeding her and
watching her mature I will also miss
giving her the fanciest possible home
there's no more terraforming so forget
an intricate backyard in fact my initial
lot was so small that there is no room
for the starting telescope forget
leaving out the things from previous
Sims expansions The Sims 4 leaves out
some of the elements that main previous
games so interesting in their vanilla
States
I missed that mad
to shower and eat before the carpool
leaves and being able to manage general
behaviors for my sims while they're at
work
some of these options will become
available as a free download I'm sure
while others will be added into
expansion packs and stuff packs which
will certainly not be free number three
no more create a style character
creation has always been a blast in the
Sims and while being able to tweak
individual facial elements is lovely I
miss being able to tweak clothing to
best suit my aesthetics The Sims series
isn't just a life simulation it's also a
virtual dollhouse having the tools to
make bathrobes and carpets look as
colorful or as silly as we want to be as
part of the charm and I'm sorry but
being able to dress up like a hot dog
isn't much of a consolation number four
it doesn't take advantage of your
hardware at first you might think that
not including a 64-bit executable is not
much to get worked up about
but it's emblematic of the entire change
in focus here presumably developer Maxis
was greatly concerned about making sure
the game ran smoothly on as many
different systems as possible the
condensed size may be sometimes
frustrating but the stuttering of the
sims 3 is in the past
I admire the game's buttery smooth
performance but I deal with a few
scattered hitches if it meant lots
weren't completely flat and remember how
we used to wish the games so-called
rabbit holes were improved you know what
I mean places like restaurants and
theaters that your sims disappeared into
what we wanted were actual stores and
schools to explore not having them just
be removed entirely I suppose the upside
is that the game runs exceedingly well
on every PC I've played it on but
honestly and somewhat unfairly I've come
to refer to the sims 4 as the Sims 1 HD
as a result I'll have a more balanced
look at the sims 4 soon but it's
important to note even now that a number
of options have been removed and I'm not
sure that the trade-offs are worth it
the sims 4 is a joy to interact with and
there's still plenty of room to guide
your Sims to success but something
doesn't feel right actually a bunch of
things just don't feel quite right
yep Zee
[Music]